- [Voiceover] What is
the area of the figure?
So down here we have this one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10-sided figure,
and we want to know its area,
how many square meters
does this figure cover?
And we have some measurements,
that seems helpful,
but what's not too helpful to me is
I don't know the special trick
to find the area of a 10-sided figure
so I've got to think about what I do know
and what I do know
is the way to find area of a rectangle.
So what I can do, because I can see,
if I can find any rectangles in here.
Here's one rectangle, right there.
So I can find the area of that part.
Then let's see if I can find any more.
Here's another rectangle.
So I can find the area of that part.
We could call that one
a rectangle or a square.
And then that leaves
us with this last part,
which is again, a rectangle.
So what we did is, we broke this up
or decomposed it into three rectangles
and now if I find out how much space
this purple one covers,
and the blue one and the green one,
if I combine those, that
would tell me the area
of the entire figure,
how much space the entire figure covers.
So let's start with this one right here.
This one is three meters long,
so we can kind of divide
that by three meters,
into three equal meters,
and then we've got a width
of two meters down here
so we can split that in half.
So if we draw those lines out,
we can see this top row is
going to cover one square meter,
two square meters, three square meters,
and then there's two rows of that,
so there's two rows
of three square meters
for a total of six square meters.
This rectangle covers six square meters,
so this part of the entire figure
covers six square meters.
The next one, our measurements
are three and a three,
so it will have three rows
of three square meters
or nine square meters,
and then finally this purple one
has three meters and nine,
so we can say it will
have three rows of nine
or nine rows of three square meters
which is 27 square meters.
So the area
of this purple section,
it covers completely 27 square meters.
The green covers nine square meters,
and the blue covered six square meters.
So, if we combine all those areas,
all those square meters it covers,
that will tell us the
area of the entire figure.
So we have six square meters,
plus nine square meters,
plus 27,
and we can solve that,
six plus nine is 15,
15 plus 27, let's see,
five ones and seven ones
is 12 ones.
We'll just find some space up there.
And
one 10 and two 10's
or a 10 and a 20
is 30.
And 30 plus 12 is 42.
So the area of the entire figure is
square
meters.